well britain's health minister has
resigned over a breach of coronavirus
restrictions that he had
implemented and strenuously enforced
matt hancock admitted breaking the rules
after a photo and video emerged of him
kissing and embracing an aide in his
office the scandal enraged fellow
government ministers and angered
millions of britons who endured months
of lockdown at the height of the
pandemic
hong kong hancock rather has made
regular appearances on
television telling people they have to
stick to the rules
i understand the enormous sacrifices
that
everybody in this country has made that
you have made
and those of us who make these rules
have got to stick by them and that's why
i've got to resign
as britain faces its highest infection
numbers since early february it's not
the most convenient time for a change of
hands
matt hancock he was as health minister
the front man in deciding the uk's
approach to the pandemic
but the first line of defense for
everybody no matter who you are no
matter how old you are
is to follow that social distancing so
that we don't pass it on
to people who will end up hospitalized
or
worse but he didn't follow his own
advice
he was seen locking lips with a
colleague in photos and videos
released by tabloid newspaper the sun
people in britain are furious having
endured tough pandemic restrictions
so there are countless breed families
around the country
who had to socially distance at funerals
were unable to hug their loved ones
we only had five people at my dad's
funeral and matt
hancock's having a jolly with um this
this lady who
who the taxpayer is paying her her wages
as well it's really
it adds insult to incredible injury
the outrage is not just among the public
but also hancock's political opponents
remember this is a time when we've seen
grandparents not able to hug
their grandchildren when we've had those
nhs workers
making sure that they followed the rules
pressure mounted
and hancock resigned soon after he
apologized for breaking rules
that he himself had set the next health
minister
will not only have to deal with the rise
of the delta variant
but also the repercussions of people
feeling betrayed
and dwe's at charlotte chelsea pill is
in london following that story for us
charlotte on friday prime minister boris
johnson refused to fire hancock saying
the matter was closed
so why did he end up resigning
right uh boris johnson prime minister
saying that he apology
accepted matt hancock's uh apology and
as you say the case
was closed but here we are the
resignation
uh has come there are many particularly
the opposition pastor main opposition
party who say the prime minister
should have acted but it's clear over
the last couple of days that the health
minister's role has just become
untenable not as not only has this been
personally extremely humiliating for the
married father of three to be been
captured in the sensational
images in the sun newspaper the leaked
cctv footage which really is
gripping the nation here this is about
so much
more than that this is about the fact
that the man who who made the rules and
as you said in your opening there
the man who preached the rules for
months and months over and over again
telling
the public here how to live their lives
then seemed to break
those very same rules at the time that
these
images were taken it was against uh
covert guidance here in the uk to to
have a
intimate uh to be close to people
outside of your
own household so it is indisputable here
that this was
a breach of that guidance and that's
just caused so much upset amongst
the public who've made so many
sacrifices like so many
around the world to stay in line with
covert guidance
and the question was can the man who has
done that then go on
to be trusted by the public this
pandemic is far from over he will have
had to continue to make public health
messages
the question is will he be listened to
and the other point to make is that this
is
uh just the latest in a series of
scandals to beset the health minister
leaked text messages allegedly from the
prime minister uh
accusing the health minister of making
missteps of not being suitable
for the role so a lot of questions about
his conduct during this pandemic and
about
this scandal will continue to follow him
yeah indeed i'm sure now
former finance minister sajid javid is
now in charge of that portfolio
it's a difficult task at a difficult
time especially
with the uk seeing a new surge of
infections with the aggressive delta
variant isn't it
right well there will be some who see
sachi javid as a safe pair of hands he
has had
a number of top roles in government
including uh finance
secretary so many will be uh confident
in in his
uh ability to handle this job going
forward but make no mistake this is one
of the biggest not the biggest role
uh outside the prime minister in
government at the moment
handling this global pandemic he
doesn't have experience with the health
uh portfolio so he will have a huge
amount to catch up on in a very short
space of time in just the next couple of
weeks decisions
will have to be made on whether the uk
continues to uh
loosen those final uh covered 19
restrictions here
so it's a it's a huge job for
this albeit very experienced minister
all right charlotte thank you dw's
charlotte chelsea pill in london